working with Steve Mariucci it's
damn-near a man versus food every single
time I see him when we're off the air
mooch how are you seeing hungry I'm
salivating like Pavlov's dog just
listening to man vs. food is it possible
Big Ben audibled out of sneaks I mean
walk me through those two fourth and
inches calls that came back well on
Pittsburgh yeah they really did I didn't
eat what did somebody insist that he
audible I didn't hear no I mean the
first time they were just asking because
thanks all right I think that was the
play call I think we all here's the
thing and.and I just heard all of what
you just said about the Falcons play
calling and the pittsburgh play calling
and whatnot sometimes coaches want to
use the element of surprise okay like
hey they're not expecting this so that's
what we're going to do they're expecting
a quarterback sneak so we're gonna do
something different and sometimes it
works and then you're a hero you're
called genius and sometimes it doesn't
work and you're called a bozo and so you
know I I thought they would sneak it I
probably would have called sneak you
know Tom Brady your guy Tom Brady I
think he's had like a hundred sneaks
hook it up like and he's made 98 of them
or something crazy all right and Big Ben
you read off 18 out of 19 and so that's
what I was expecting that's what I think
you know Jags were expecting and then
they flip it outside and lose five yards
it's like what and then and then another
one later on it's it's just amazing you
know you tried it you try to use the
element of surprise sometimes and it
doesn't it didn't work two times in a
row on fourth downs for the Steelers
well now the Jenkins of the Eagles said
they practiced six times during the week
against the play call that Steve
Sarkisian and Matt Ryan employed on that
fourth down play knowing the hash mark
and knowing that I guess there's film
study and and so what did you make of
that fourth down play on on Saturday no
I don't know night Steve yeah just
because they they practice that doesn't
mean that you're going to stop it
because that's you know when you play
the West Coast offense rich you practice
against print option okay it's been
right or splint left option
there are a lot of different formations
and in different ways of getting to it I
like the way they did it I don't
criticize the call at all because it
should have been a touchdown it
they got double coverage on the slot
guys I knew for some reason they got
single coverage on Julio that's what you
would pray for in a situation when
you're trying to win the game one-on-one
with Julio Jones they cut the edge with
a motion tight end I like that way of
doing it the back he blocked the back
edge he wasn't part of the progression
Matt Ryan looked back to him when he
fell down just be God of thought of
desperation he's not part of that whole
thing it's the front side and Julio
Jones slipped he slipped if he plants if
he looks up for the fade plants drops
his shoulder pads and comes back to the
pylon they probably win that game and I
mentioned to it like we talked about it
on the air if you go back and watch
Derek Carr and the Raiders they called a
similar play in fact remember Derek said
that was our play call but I I flipped
it over to the left because I we had
kind of runs something similar earlier
in the game and he threw a touchdown to
win the game to Crabtree it's a good
call if you get single coverage on that
and so I'm not going to criticize the
call I'm going to criticize the
execution on the play and then even
after the improvised Julio Jones had a
chance to catch that ball he went right
through his hands but then one foot was
out of bounds to it it was just that's
how it goes sometimes Steve Mariucci
joining me here on the Rich Eisen show
and so let's get to it
I mean the way that that Viking Saints
game ended oh my god well you've been on
on the positive side of things with the
New York giant I guess fake or the fake
kick and all that sort of business but
you were up on that one on the botched
snap I mean what what in the world is
Sean Payton do right now this morning
Steve you know I think he's got to just
take a deep breath and go we did
everything we could
to put ourselves fight back from down 17
and get in a position to play great in
the second half and get ahead that thing
changed Leeds four times in the last few
minutes what
spectacular game I kale called me she
was driving home from SAMHSA's she said
I was listening to it on the radio I had
to pull over because it was so exciting
I was losing my mind and she had a
pullover she couldn't drive her car
during that that excitement and and and
so it's a it's a fluke II play I feel
bad for the kid that ducked under the
tackle and you know and and missed it
and and allowed that touchdown maybe he
thought he was going to get pass
interference or something and if the if
the Vikings win the Super Bowl
okay it turns into a play like it's a
catch where it's an iconic play forever
and ever
now if they lose the next game we kind
of forget about it a little bit you know
but if that thing turns into a Super
Bowl win that will be the reason they
got there it was a miracle in the US
Bank Stadium and I still can't get over
it it was oh my god
what'd he say to the kid Marcus Williams
who out of the quarter yeah option they
know I was up for for the Saints win so
what do you say to him
yeah that's a hard one you know I don't
know what I don't know what he's going
through today you know I don't know what
he went through in that locker room
because everybody's looking at him like
what did you do what what was that you
know and I did anything any reporter put
a microphone in his face did Steve and
he wiped the tears away you could see he
was red-eyed bleary face bloated face
and he stood there in front of his
locker and answered every question what
did he say that it was he trying to
avoid he didn't rap you just tried to
torpedo in there cut legs out I got or
something What did he say
that he would do a better job the next
time I don't think he really gave too
much voice to the thought process cuz
yeah I don't even know that for him
because it was a you know all he has to
do even if even if there's a catch you
know make the tackle and that's probably
it you know um but he missed and it
allowed the touchdown and he wiped out
his teammate could who could have made
attack overall he was awful I know it
was he made a better tackle on his own
teammate I mean it's it really is
nightmarish stuff to watch it over and
over and over again for a saint he had
the interception in the game
I mean Hey look him in Latimore and and
and Crawley guys in their first and
second year and that's secondary it's
another reason why you know the Saints
have a tremendously bright future it's
just a bad time to pull a rookie rock
quite frankly you know and then it did
they drafted well and then on the other
side of the ball - with the Camaro and
RAM second you know they got a lot of
good young kids on there they just they
just got a hope hope and pray they can
figure out a way to keep drew brees
around a few you know the year or two
because this this young Saints team is
really talented and if they can shake
this off they got to be able to shake
this off they did play well enough to
come back and win they really should
have won but a fluke plate just beat
them and you gotta just shake your head
it's uh it's a shame they got to find a
way to get the next year Steve Mariucci
and the man vs. food coaches
conversation here on the Rich Eisen show
Brockman is just he's giddy because he
thinks you know all my Patriots had to
do is beat Marcus Mariota now it's Blake
bortles and then two other guys who have
never done it before for Brady to win
his sixth walk me through talk which
which one do you think's got the better
best chance of beating New England first
up well or second up which one yeah III
I just I just say I think that Jags
defense was exposed a little bit this
week you know they they have a great
young defense too and and but Big Ben
you just had his way you know he had for
69 yards passing and Brady's got to be
looking at this and going you know we
can we can complete passes to and and so
you know I think I think at home they
have they have a pretty I don't want to
say easy time because the Jags I just
you know texted Tom Coughlin to
congratulate him and he's crediting the
coaches and the players like he would
you know and and they they deserve to be
here that's it's unbelievable that Steve
would stop right there do you think I
who was prevented Brady twice when it
looked like he was gonna keep winning
again it's Coughlin does he have the
secret sauce and do the Jaguars have
what he had at his disposal
without obviously the good front a
defensive front right there
I don't Grady in the pocket and does he
have that kind of a front you know what
he built his team to do this now with
coleus Campbell and Malik Jackson and in
Marcel Darius he's really added to that
front and maybe it's for games like this
and so and then you talk about the two
best pair of corners in the league - you
know I mean as long as hey how much have
we been talking about all week about
these two inadequate quarterbacks Blake
bortles and Nick Foles and you know what
they got the last laugh since both of
them played good enough to advance to
the championship game I hats off to
those guys they both played very well
and it was kind of like a I belong here
too and and so yeah defenses are good
but these these these two unexpected
quarterbacks are all of a sudden playing
good playoff football well well let's
finish up then with something that's
also definitely not a fluke from the
sporting weekend that would be Michigan
winning in the Breslin Center against
your best man I thought we put that to
bed
oh no that's still quite awake Stephen I
talked to you man he was maybe he's
gonna call in no he won't
he lost Mike he lost my number
all of a sudden yeah the numbers not on
the top of his mind right now if he
would have won this game maybe you had a
call and I don't know but you know what
the worst part about it the worst part
about that whole loss they don't get a
chance to play Michigan again in the
regular season from baby that's just
they're gonna have to wait for the
tournament that's the [ __ ] Oh anyway you
wait you wait hey you guys you know what
you guys deserve to win that game oh
you're so kind that was hard for me you
know for you to say that they're kind of
almost but really doesn't make me feel
bad that I had a viral video of you
being informed of the score thinking you
were taking a selfie and then getting a
ring is it'll calling in on the other
line right now he's not says he says you
know what to tell rich he says yeah yeah
that's good Steve it's all good all
right all right take care but we'll see
for the monster meeting on game day
morning on Saturday first okay go sorry
the Rich Eisen show weekdays
noon eastern on audience